in your new Journal
you say that you think that having
understanding your principles or having
principles can save you something like a
hundred thousand decisions I don't know
if it's a hundred thousand decisions in
a lifetime or 100 000 decisions in a
year what do you mean by them how does
that work
um what I mean by that is
that most people look at a lot of things
that are coming at them as these
individual things lots of these things
coming at you every day how many
decisions do we make in a day
when you start to think in principles
you think differently you see that the
thing that is coming at you you say what
species is it and how do I deal with
that species right so you don't see them
as all these individual things that are
coming that that blizzard that you're in
you just see Ah that's that and here's
how I deal with that
and it makes decision so it's much much
less
stuff coming at you and you have that
orderly way of dealing with it